sponsored by Playstation
[Music]
hello guys my name is Ricardo Sanchez
I'm the first international GT Academy
winner and here are some tips to become
a champion in the GT sport game hey
everyone its NIC margarita standing in
for Ricardo Sanchez on his tips for Gran
Turismo sport sponsored by Playstation
tip number one draft your opponents to
gain a small but valuable burst of speed
drafting is the term for riding close to
another racer in front of you a maneuver
which allows you to take advantage of
their wind resistance and go slightly
faster than you would otherwise just be
careful not to bump into them as doing
so will only slow you down
tip number two learn the out in out
technique the most difficult aspect of
racing is taking turns without losing
speed or running off the track start
from the outside of the track angling
your car to meet the apex of the turn
then once you've aligned with a straight
exit to the next stretch of road put the
pedal to the metal tip number three turn
off driving assists to learn proper
techniques assists are helpful but they
limit your ability to fully control your
cars when you feel comfortable try
racing without any help and be sure to
pay attention to the campaigns various
lessons as they'll teach you a lot
you'll use down the road tip number four
learn how to drive manual rather than
automatic while you can of course rely
on automatic gear shifting and Gran
Turismo sport you will be robbed of a
critical capability downshifting
downshifting will not only help you
increase torque while taking turns but
it also helps you manage your speed tip
number five drive using the first person
camera driving with your view set within
the car or on the hood gives you a far
more useful vantage point to judge your
vehicle sense of speed which in turn
helps you properly judge trajectory and
velocity did we miss anything if so
share your grant trees most sport tips
in the comments below and as always
thanks for watching for more on Gran
Turismo sport just click on the link
[Music]
you